[ __ ] now Florida Attorney General Pam
Bondi and Fox News legal analyst Gregg
Jarrett let me start with John Solomon
who will join us in a minute let's start
with all of these revelations ray and
and Peter struck and all of these
figures Hillary Clinton supporters Trump
haters I think we now know that the
Muller investigation is illegitimate and
corrupt and Muller has been using the
FBI as a political weapon and the FBI
has become America's secret police
secret surveillance wiretapping
intimidation harassment and threats it's
like the old KGB that comes for you in
the dark of the night banging through
you see this is not a game this is not a
hyperbole you're using here no ask Paul
Manafort they came for him and broke
through his front door and if it can
happen to him
Gregg it can happen to all of us
absolutely
the FBI is a shadow government now it
has become highly politicized Peter
struck is the perfect example of it he
led both the Hillary Clinton
investigation and until recently the
Muller investigation this is a guy who
has corrupt political motives we now
know it we've the Congress has the
emails but he's the tip of the iceberg
there are others especially Andrew
Weissman and as you pointed out Jeanne
ray you're the Attorney General of
Florida I have been laying out a case
and it just keeps growing by leaps and
bounds and in fact I am saying with the
with the surveillance the unmasking and
the leaking of raw intelligence we now
have some members I want to be very
clear I think the vast majority of our
intelligence community are FBI they are
good people that serve us and do a great
job and keep us safe but we have some
that are using the powerful tools of
intelligence they have weaponized it as
in the case of general Flynn and we have
now criminalized and politicized at the
highest levels starting with James Comey
and Muller and his band of merry you
know Trump haters
you know criminalizing and politicizing
the Justice Department and justice in
America how dangerous is this you you
and Greg have laid out an incredible
case every night and here's why it's so
important as an attorney general to me
the Justice Department and as it should
be to the rest of the country should
exhibit the height of objectivity they
should be objective in everything they
do for good reason because this is all
about the rule of law everything that we
fight for is state attorneys general
every single day of our careers and then
to see this happen and the way you're
laying it out it would be so easy to
find a team as you said there are so
many great people in the Justice
Department they're these people that
shouldn't be donating to political
campaigns they could whack them off the
list of being involved right off the bat
then we have struck everything you've
laid out about struck Lisa Paige his
girlfriend Weissman who the Sally Yates
email alone praising her for defying the
President of the United States who was
her boss so that's what's so troubling
this team that has been assembled when
Shaun you and Greg have laid out the
perfect case why they shouldn't be on
the team people out there how else do
you explain that the FBI can interview
Huma Abedin and Cheryl Mills and even
though they lied in the documents prove
it they were not charged with lying to
the FBI Flynn was Flynn was because he
deviated fractionally from the tape
recorded conversation the FBI obtained
illegally of his disk illegally of his
discussion with a Russian ambassador I
mean that just underscores the rampant
corruption here by the government wait
go ahead yeah let me add to that Mike
Flynn thing okay not only they have him
they're using him obviously flipping him
as a witness which we all know is common
to do but this is a man who now has lied
to the vice president that they've
they've caught saying he's lied to the
FBI
they're using his son hanging his son
over his head to force them to be away
by the way tell us what we want to hear
or ma'am we may have to go after your
son it's extortion its threats its bribe
when you and I do it it's illegal and
we're thrown behind bars when the
government does it they applaud
themselves this is the biggest
corruption we have ever seen in terms of
our justice system I believe in our
lifetime thank you both appreciate it
great work both of you